So I roughly said that I wouldn't show up to the side of the game tonight, so
I took over the supervision of the study instead.
I have
a request for Miyata, but he'll listen to
me.I'll work hard and study from tomorrow, so
let's go on a
date.  What are you going to do when
dart goes out with two
bodies?  I know you want to go out with me, but where are
you going
?  So, by all means, I want a Ennin no Hoshi
Hmmm
Village car n Damn it's super cute Let's
go, but it might end up causing trouble for clinging to it
Mera's people and children are innocent and seriously angelic army
Lee Yukinari
I understand  It can't be
helped, so I'll stay with you Come down from the flower garden, Wonder-kun, seriously,
if that's what makes Subaru motivated from tomorrow, I'll go out with you.
It's going to be a bad day,
Subaru is like that
Sister
Subaru5  It's a reward because you can